beim nächsten Mal wenn wir uns sehen
sind wir bei einem Zuschauer zu Hause
und wenn ihr mitmachen möchtet dann
könnt ihr euch gerne
[Musik]
bewerben F my kitchen geht in die fünfte
Runde und heute bekommt jemand von euch
also jemand aus der Community eine
brandneue Küche ihr habt euch fleißig
beworben und von über 10.000 Bewerbungen
haben wir einen Gewinner rausgezogen er
selbst möchte die Küche aber gar nicht
haben aber dazu gleich mehr aber um was
geht's bei pimp my kitchen geht's darum
euch zu zeigen wie man Küchen richtig
plant worauf es ankommt und ich gebe
euch zusätzlich nützliche und kreative
Tipps zum einräumen und organisieren
eurer Küche und natürlich auch zum
Dekorieren der Küche und da ist es
wirklich völlig egal ob es eine
Mitarbeiterküche ist eine Küche für den
Kindergarten einen Promi oder ob ich
damit jemanden von euch überrasche g
Muffin und jetzt zurück zu Freddy warum
möchte eigentlich die Küche nicht für
sich selbst haben Freddys Eltern haben
seit über 30 Jahren ein und dieselbe
Küche und mit der Zeit kam die Küche
natürlich in die Jahre und deswegen
möchte Freddy seine Eltern zum Dank mit
einer neuen Küche überraschen richtig
süß von
ihm und um Fredy Thomas und Annemarie
von ihrem Glück zu erzählen bin ich nach
Ditzingen gefahren und habe mir gedacht
ich Besuch sie mal bei der Arbeit um sie
dort zu überraschen wir sind gerade hier
in Ditzingen im Kreis Ludwigsburg bei
der Feuerwehr wir gehen jetzt hier
gleich rein haben was richtig cooles
geplant und dann werden beide heute
überrascht mit einem Großeinsatz in der
Küche
da sind wir in der Umkleide der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal die Kleidung von der
Nadin schlüpft da
rein oh
Gott Freiwillige Feuerwehr sallyö die
schönste Küche Deutschlands für Sie im
[Musik]
Einsatz
hallo hier ist die freiwillige Feuerwehr
aus wheusel und zwar geht's um einen
Großeinsatz es muss eine neue Küche her
pimp my kitchen 5 Anne Marie und Thomas
ihr habt gewonnen ihr seid die
glücklichen Gewinner von F my kitchen
ich denke mal die Überraschung ist
geglückt also lasst uns jetzt keine Zeit
verlieren und die alte Küche von Ann
Marie und Thomas
anschauen so da sind wir Anne Marie hier
ist eure Küche jawohl die sehe ich ja
jetzt auch zum ersten Mal tatsächlich
ich muss sagen auf den Fotos und im
Bewerbungsvideo saah ein bisschen größer
aus aber die ist ja doch recht schön
gemütlich klein ja ich se die ist schon
in die Jahre gekommen sie ist ziemlich
in die Jahre gekommen hast du so gesehen
ne was gefällt dir an deiner Küche und
was gefällt dir denn nicht vielleicht
kannst du mir das mal sagen ich fange
mit dem positiven an das ist die
Arbeitsfläche also weil wir wirklich
ganz viele Leute immer zu messen haben
und dann kann man als Buffet das auch
gut machen also das heiß etwas an dem
ich wirklich hänge das ist das ja und
ansonsten sonst gefällt mir eigentlich
nicht so viel mehr da drin so viel
Stauraum brauchst duahchein das ja und
so viel brauche ich jetzt tatsächlich
nicht me z.B die Bücher da die kön man
ruhig auch wegdenken dann schöne
Kochbücher es fehlt nur noch meins dabei
bring ich dann mit ja ja ja wunderbar
wunderbar das auch könnte man sich auch
anders vorstellen aber das benutze ich
ganz Stk viel weil ich bin espressoante
also und also auch deutsche Kaffee und
ich habe ganz viel Sorten auch Espresso
immer und was ganz doof ist ist also die
Tür wir denken daran das vielleicht als
schieetür irgendwie zu gestalten man
quasi die Wand aufbrechen kann
irgendwie ja also mal schauen wie wir
das noch regeln könnten hier haben wir
auch so ein Teil weiß ich nicht das mit
diese Putzsachen ob man das nicht auch
irgendwo unterbringen könnte und und und
Wissen generell für dich ich sehe die
Küche geht ja bis hoch zur Decke ja also
das ist nicht gut dein Mann ist ja recht
groß hast du immer Hocker ja also alles
ranzukommen ja und und manchmal also mit
dem da und mit den Knie h ich da was
hoch ja also du musst wahrscheinlich
viel Staugut was du generell immer mal
wieder brauchst dann würde ich auch
schauen dass du alles deswegen muss ich
d auch gleich bisschen besser
kennenlernen alles was du oft brauchst
auf deine Höhe und alles was wir selner
brauchen da gibt's Systeme guck mal das
ist ja die ganzen Backformen tart und
Kisch ja das ist vier ein K wo was ich
dir zeigen kann das ist die Rezepte
meiner Mutter zum 80 ich das so
geschenkt und das ist das was sie uns
gemacht hat und wo sie
herk für Mama und die Kinder ja ich habe
auch so Bilder mit meinem Papa und der
Wassermelone toll oder ach Gott das
schön und das sind die
Rezepte ja also das ist ja es war viel
Arbeit ich habe bisschen dreichprachen
dann übersetzt für alle neen ja
klar ist schön so ein richtiges
Familienalbum vielleicht können wir auch
mal dann wenn die Küche fertig ist so
ein kleinen pastakurs machen
hier schön ja okay ja da bin ich ganz
stolz drauf weil ja schön das wird
richtig toll ich freue mich so sehr
drauf denn es wird so ein richtig
schöner vorher nachher Effekt glaube ich
ich glaube die zwei freuen sich richtig
damit ich eine Küche planen kann die
natürlich perfekt zu Thomas und
Annemarie passt muss ich erstmal wissen
was gefällt den den beiden deswegen
eignen sich hier küchenkataloge super
weil man sich da ganz toll inspirieren
lassen kann und eben schon mal schauen
kann was gefällt und was z.B gar nicht
gefällt wollt ihr eine moderne Küche
wollt ihr eine Landhausküche hell dunkel
farbig eh moderner diese Neuheiten da
ist alles was ganz neu drin ist das ist
alles so dunkel aber Farbe ich mir schon
was rot schon bloß wenn es rostrot ist
gefällt mir nicht das ist auch sehr
dunkel Farben git momentan kaum genau
schaut mal hier
z.B easy touch tobgrau dann hat's eine
easy Touch in diesem sandfarben das
ist das ist gut jetzt weiß ich ja was
den beiden gefällt und was ihnen auch so
gar nicht gefällt im küchenkatalog
konnte ich schon einige Inspirationen
bekommen aber ich fahre jetzt noch
gemeinsam mit euch zu Nobilia nach Ferl
denn auf der Küchenmesse kann man sich
noch mal so richtig inspirieren lassen
und da könnt ihr euch selbst auch gerne
anmelden falls ihr auf der Suche nach
einer neuen Küche seid denn die Küchen
kann man anfassen erleben die Schränke
öffnen und einfach Neuheiten entdecken
warum lieb ich alles was so grün
ist vielleicht wird ja auch meine neue
Küche grün so wie hier Jade Jade ist
nämlich eine neue Farbe in der
sensorfront und es ist wirklich eine
ganz ganz tolle Farbe komm ich zeig s
euch
mal hier ist sie die sensoyade eine
absolute Trendfarbe und ich sag's euch
die hat so ein richtig softes mattes
Finish wodurch sie sich richtig weich
und ganz angenehm anfühlt vor allem ist
es aber auch eine Front die zu ein 100%
aus recycleltem Material besteht und
dafür auch ausgezeichnet wurde und was
ich ganz toll finde sie hat die
antiingerprint Beschichtung und ist
natürlich auch extrem kratz
unempfindlich ich glaube das wird meine
neue lieblingsfront und vielleicht seht
ihr auch mein Studio in dieser Farbe wer
[Musik]
weiß jetzt habe ich einige Inspirationen
und weiß schon ungefähr in der Theorie
wie die Küche aussehen soll jetzt geht's
aber in die richtige Planung ich habe
jetzt hier eine relativ kleine Küche in
die aber viel Stauraum muss das heißt
ihr könnt euch jetzt hier erst einmal
überlegen was sind denn die küchenzonen
ich habe einmal die küchenzone spülen
und Müll die küchenzone vorbereiten in
der Lebensmittel zum Kochen vorbereitet
werden ich habe die küchenzone Kochen
und Backen aufbewahren anrichten also
Geschir und Besteck und natürlich auch
Lebensmittel bevorr
der spülplatz ist natürlich schon
vorddefiniert weil ich da die
Abflussrohre schon habe das heißt der
spülplatz wird sich vom Platz her nicht
verändern den ganzen unteren Bereich
werde ich mit Korpussen ausstatten damit
ich hier möglichst viel Stauraum habe
auch besonders gerade die Ecken die
normalerweise immer so tote Zonen sind
die komplette rechte Seite bekommt dann
noch Hochschränke damit dort auch viel
Stauraum unterkommt und zum anderen auch
Elektrogeräte und Kühlschrank reinpassen
und auch ein kleiner
hauswirtschaftsschrank der obere Bereich
der rechten Seite wird dann noch schön
ausgestattet für Geschirr das heißt dort
kommen noch Vitrinen mit rein mit
Glasfronten und dort wird auch ein
bisschen indirektes Licht mit eingebaut
damit das Ganze so ein warmes Ambiente
bekommt und auch vom Licht her so ein
bisschen heller wird auf die Spülenseite
kommen auch einige Hängeschränke in die
auch ganz viel Stau gut reinpasst Anne
Marie und Thomas war ja auch ganz
wichtig dass Sie eine extrem große freie
Arbeitsfläche haben zum Arbeiten und zum
Abstellen das bedeutet die komplette
Fensterfront ist Arbeitsfläche und wird
durch nichts unterbrochen die übrig
gebliebene Seite ist das Kochfeld
sozusagen die Kochzone und auch dort
wird alles optimal ausgenutzt damit kein
Platz verschwendet wird ich denke so ist
die Küche jetzt optimal geplant ich habe
alle Küchengeräte integriert habe ein
tolles Farbkonzept auch ein tolles
Lichtkonzept mit indirekter Beleuchtung
und habe einfach ein super schönes
Ambiente geschaffen die Küche kann jetzt
bestellt werden und wird dann von Mario
und Claudio
[Musik]
eingebaut
um die Küche jetzt auch optisch gut zu
gestalten habe ich mich jetzt hier für
zwei Farben entschieden und zwar nehme
ich zum einen die Nobilia Front Touch in
lacklaminat aqua supermat kombiniere
dazu eine extra Arbeitsplatte in Eiche
Artisan die hat eine ganz tolle
3dstuktur und sieht einfach aus wie
echtes Holz ist aber viel unempfind
und man kann eben richtig toll drauf
arbeiten das ganze wird dann noch
kombiniert mit einem Bügelgriff in
schwarz und mit XL Korpusen und da kann
man wirklich auch die Arbeitshöhe selbst
bestimmen XL corpus bedeutet ich habe
extra viel Stauraum und kann dann mit
der Sockelhöhe variieren und natürlich
auch mit der Dicke der Arbeitsfläche und
so die optimale ergonomische Höhe für
jede Körpergröße bestimmen wie schön ist
bitte diese Küche geworden ich bin
richtig begeistert ich finde aus dem
Raum ist einfach ein völlig anderer Raum
entstanden und jetzt geht's ans Küchen
hier einräumen ich habe euch ja schon
öfter in meinen Videos die Tipps gegeben
zum Küche einräumen am besten schaut ihr
mal auf meinen Blog vorbei da gibt's
nämlich einen Blogbeitrag Küche
organisieren ihr könnt nämlich
verschiedene küchenzonen einrichten so
wie ich es euch auch schon bei der
Planung gesagt habe das heißt ich habe
jetzt hier meine Post jetzt schon bereit
werde hier alle Schränke bekleben dann
alles was ich einrichten möchte schön
sortieren und die Küche einrichten ich
freue mich das ist so schön ich würde
mal sagen hier kommt direkt Geschir und
bestick
[Musik]
immer schön ans arbeitsdreieck denken
auch in kleinen Küchen Spüle Kochen
vorbereiten alles am besten an einer
Stelle dass man nicht so oft hin und her
[Musik]
muss
ja hier in der Küche waren viele
Lebensmittel offen und ich weiß dass
viele das auch so Hand haben dass Sie
sie einfach offen wieder verschließen
oder Klammern drum machen es ist aber
tatsächlich besser dass ihr eure
Lebensmittel direkt dann luftdicht
verpackt den Vorratsbehälter z.B zum
einen habt ihr den besseren Überblick
ihr könnt Vorratsbehälter auch stapeln
ihr habt den Durchblick falls Sie auch
schön durchsichtig sind und sie sind
einfach geschützt geschützt vor Motten
z.B man nimmt sich ja oft auch Motten
mit aus dem Supermarkt nach Hause sowas
entsteht eigentlich nicht im Haushalt
sondern ist irgendwo schon mit drin
verbreitet sich dann leider auch recht
schnell hatte ich auch schon und dann
ist es immer gut wenn man
Vorratsbehälter hat die luftdicht sind
und man einfach alles übersichtlich hat
und zum anderen sind Lebensmittel dann
auch länger haltbar weil kein Sauerstoff
dran kommt und natürlich auch kein Staub
und kein Schmutz alles ist schön
geschützt übersichtlich und praktisch
[Musik]
sortiert hier über dem Kochfeld habe ich
einen Schrank mit der Dunstabzugshaube
und da werde ich jetzt schauen dass ich
hier trotzdem den Schrank und den Platz
den ich noch übrig habe sinnvoll nutzen
kann ihr könnt hier z.B den Vorrat
reinmachen für Küchenrolle dann habe ich
hier ein Küchenrollenhalter der kommt
hierm
rein denn ich mag nicht so gerne offene
Küchenrolle irgendwo in der Küche stehen
zu haben dann hat man das ganz praktisch
[Musik]
hier
pimp my kitchen wä nicht pimp my kitchen
wenn sich hier nicht auch ein
Gewinnspiel verstecken würde deswegen
gibt's für euch jetzt die Chance was
Großes zu gewinnen ihr seht hier schon
neben mir aufgebaut eine Gusseisen ein
gusseisentopf eine wenpfanne und ein
Messer ihr dürft gerne entscheiden
welche warbenpfanne ihr möchtet die
kleine oder die große ob kuseisentopf
alime Ella Samira oder Baba oder
whatever und welche Farbe natürlich auch
und welches Messer ihr haben wollt
santuko masuta oder
schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare und
oben drauf lege ich euch noch einen 500
€ Gutschein für Sally Shop da könnt ihr
euch mal richtig austoben denn auch wenn
ich es nicht zu euch nach Hause in die
Küche geschafft habe und nicht eure
Küche gepimpt habe könnt ihr euch damit
mit diesem Gewinn einfach eure Küche ein
bisschen selber
pimpen die Küche ist jetzt fertig
eingeräumt und ich mache jetzt mal eine
Küchen room Tour mit euch also ich zeige
euch jetzt mal alle Schränke die wir
hier so haben ihr seht hier direkt im
Hintergrund habe ich ja die Vitrinen und
da eignet sich natürlich einfach die
Aufbewahrung von Geschirr und von
Gläsern und falls ihr auch Geschir habt
was ihr doppelt stapeln wollt um
Stauraum eben auch zu sparen und den
Stauraum optimal auszunutzen könnt ihr
hier noch so kleine Regale mit
einbringen und hier habe ich einfach
weil ich die Kaffeemaschine hier
aufgebaut habe eben die Tassen das
Geschirr für jeden Tag hier oben noch
teevorräte oder auch
ofenformen und hier links einfach alles
was an Gläsern eben da ist und ich habe
auch hier bewusst das ganze so rum
eingerichtet dass hier die Gläser sind
weil die schön leicht sind man kommt gut
hin auch wenn man vielleicht etwas
kleiner ist und eben an dieser Ecke
vielleicht schwerer an die oberen
Schränke kommt und hier dann eben das
sperrigere das Geschirr was ein bisschen
schwerer ist dass man eben alles schön
ordentlich einräumen kann auf der
küchentäe lagere ich am liebsten fast
gar nichts außer so ein bisschen
dekoratives aber auch nützliches so wie
jetzt hier die Kaffeemaschine die
kaffeeboden dazu vielleicht noch so ein
bisschen Kekse dazu falls man zum Kaffee
was servieren will hier noch ein paar
Kochen Backbücher hier habe ich jetzt
die Kenwood COOKING CHEF connect in der
Farbe schwarz auf dem gleitbrett von
Candy professional da kann man es
nämlich dann schön aus der Ecke
herausziehen und dann eben ganz einfach
wieder nach hinten schieben ohne dabei
die empfindlichen Füße der kwood COOKING
CHEF Connect zu beschädigen das
gleitbrät verfügt auch über ein MBL das
heißt wenn es hier etwas dunkler ist und
unsere filmlichter raus sind hat man
auch eine schöne indirekte Beleuchtung
sowohl in der Küche hier in der Nische
als auch in der Vitrine oder eben auch
in der Kenwood dann zeig ich euch hier
direkt noch die Schränke ich habe hier
in dem kompletten Hochschrank ganz
rechts einen hauswirtschaftsschrank
daneben ist der Kühlschrank mit
Gefrierfach hier ist der backofenschrank
da oben habe ich ein paar backsachen die
Backbleche habe hier z.B auch die
ofenhandschuhe dass man direkt dran
kommt und eben ofenformen unter dem
Backofen ganz praktisch hier mit dem
individuellen Holzeinsatz könnt ihr
nämlich ganz wunderbar den Stauraum
ausnutzen ihr habt diese Abtrennungen
und die absteckregale die könnt ihr da
reinsetzen und z.B Backformen die sich
normalerweise nicht so gut stapeln
lassen wie Muffinformen oder hier diese
tartformen die Obstkuchenform oder auch
andere backsachen die könnt ihr hier
wunderbar verstauen ohne das alles
verrutscht hier habe ich den Bereich
Backen das heißt hier in der schubblade
so ein paar kleine Backhelfer die hier
super organisiert sind die auch immer
schnell griffbereit sein sollten
dann den backvorrat der aber
verschlossen ist hier im Haushalt gibt's
nämlich keinen Hauswirtschaftsraum das
heißt alle Vorräte die man in der Küche
braucht sollten auch hier verstaut
werden das heißt hier sind die Vorräte
die geschlossen sind die man sich dann
hier rausnehmen
kann und hier unten so die ich nenne s
jetzt mal die herzhaften Vorräte also
sowas wie Bohnen Nudeln Milch alles was
hier unten so reinpasst dann haben wir
hier einen wunderschönen
Apothekerschrank auf perfekt
ergonomischer Höhe hier habe ich einfach
noch so zwei Körbe mit reingepackt und
im Apothekerschrank verstaue ich total
gerne essigöl und die ganzen
Flüssigkeiten und Soßen die es hier im
Haushalt natürlich auch schon gab und da
hat man einfach alles perfekt im
Überblick und kann sogar die Tablare
hier auf den Ebenen Höhen verstellen das
heißt wenn ihr mal was höheres habt oder
was niedrigeres einfach die Tablare
verstellen was in der Küche auch optimal
genutzt ist sind die Ecken die quasi
eigentlich tot sind und zwar habe ich
hier insgesamt drei Ecken die tot sind
es wä einmal diese Ecke hier hinten und
damit es eben keine tote Ecke ist gibt's
hier einfach einen Schrank mit diesen
drehauszügen ich habe jetzt hier den
gusseisentopf drin der einfach sehr
schwer ist aber der einfach auf perfekt
ergonomischer Höhe eingeräumt ist das
heißt wenn hier Annemarie den Topf
braucht oder oder Thomas können Sie es
hier einfach rausnehmen hier wieder
verstauen und den Rest habe ich jetzt
hier noch gar nicht eingeräumt denn es
ist auch Platz da falls Sie sich noch
was zulegen oder doch was von ihren
eigenen Sachen noch mit Reinräumen
möchten weil ich jetzt natürlich nicht
alles eingeräumt habe aber schon so
größtenteils hier oben ist direkt das
Besteck eingeräumt passt perfekt weil
hier die Kaffeemaschine ist bei der man
eben auch die Löffel vielleicht braucht
das Geschirr Besteck alles hier was man
so zum Tisch richten eben
braucht hier haben wir die Spülmaschine
auch schön
eingeplant und hier in der Ecke habe ich
es ganz anders gelöst ich habe hier
nämlich den lemont eingebaut das ist der
Nieren Schrank der auch hier zwei
Tablare und zwei Regalböden sozusagen
hat und der ist auch perfekt weil er bis
in die Ecke reingeht und man ihn eben
rausnehmen kann das heißt alles was groß
und sperrig ist kann hier verstaut
werden auch perfekt ergonomischer Höhe
ich nutze den ganz gerne für Töpfe es
passen aber auch z.B große Rührschüsseln
rein oder auch Küchengeräte die ihr
vielleicht weiter hinten verstauen wollt
und hier oben habe ich jetzt die Töpfe
drin da unten sind die Pfannen das zeige
ich euch auch was ist auch ein cooler
lifehack eigentlich für die Küche wenn
ihr nämlich auch antihaftbeschichtete
Pfannen habt wie meine wabenpfannen die
möchte man ja schützen man will nicht
dass sie zerkratzen und dann könnt ihr
hier als pfannenschutz sozusagen die
kochblume verwenden die kochblume ist
ein Überlaufschutz ein überkochschutz
wenn ihr Nudeln kocht Kartoffeln oder
z.B auch Linsen die ganz gerne mal
Überkochen dann nehmt ihr die kochblume
und nichts kocht mehr über bei euch in
der Küche und dann könnt ihr hier die
kochblume zwischen euren Pfannen
verstauen schützt eure Pfannen vor
Kratzern und die kochblume ist perfekt
verstaut hier habe ich auch noch den
bratdeckel den zeige ich euch auch mal
der ist auch perfekt weil ihr so mit dem
bratdeckel alles knusprig anbraten könnt
was normalerweise ohne Deckel gebraten
werden sollte das ist hier so ein
Glasdeckel und der hat hier diese
Einkerbungen das heißt ihr könnt den auf
jede Pfannengröße verwenden und ihr
setzt den bratdeckel auf habt hier so
ein Ventil was ihr steuern könnt und
könnt dann z.B auch Fischstäbchen
knusprig braten ohne dass aber alles
eben in der Küche herumspritzt der ist
wirklich super
gute lieben wir ich geh hier nämlich
direkt an mein arbeitsdreieck und zwar
habe ich hier den Wasserplatz den
Kochplatz und alles was Vorbereitung ist
hier oben habe ich meinen
Lebensmittelvorrat und habe hier damit
Annemarie auch super dran kommt den eove
mit eingebaut der iMOVE dient dazu hier
den kompletten Schrankinhalt einfach
nach unten zu ziehen mit einer
Handbewegung das heißt alles was ihr
hier drin habt kommt auf die perfekte
Höhe hier oben habe ich einfach mal die
grobvorräte die man vielleicht nicht
jeden Tag braucht wie Kaffee Tee oder
Porridge und Haferflocken und hier
einfach alle offenen trockenen Vorräte
die wir z.B zum Backen brauchen hier
unten genauso und ihr könnt hier wenn
ihr nicht so viele offene Vorräte habt
z.B auch noch mal anderes Kochgeschirr
verstauen und habt dann hier einfach
drei Ebenen die ihr optimal ausnutzen
könnt hier habe ich noch mal eine schöne
Vitrine eingebaut und ich finde auch die
macht hier einfach ein wunderschönes
Licht ich habe hier das indirekte Licht
unter den Hängeschränken das Licht in
den Vitrinen und es bringt einfach so
eine total warme Stimmung mit
rein dann dachte ich mir wenn Sie doch
mal ein bisschen mehr Besuch bekommen
und doch etwas mehr Geschirr brauchen
oder bowls und Schalen brauchen ist das
ganze hier auch für Snacks geeignet hier
noch ein paar süße kleine Pfannen falls
Sie sich morgens mal ein Frühstück
machen wollen und die Pfannen verwenden
die Gewürzmühle für Salz und Pfeffer und
hier
oben auch einfach noch mal Platz für
weitere Vorräte und hier gibt's auch was
ziemlich cooles ihr könnt nämlich
einfach so kleine Boxen nehmen und hier
wirklich alles thematisch sortieren z.B
Ausstecher ihr könnt da gewürzvorräte
reinmachen Tee verstauen und wenn das
ganze dann noch Deckel habt so wie hier
dann ist es eben auch perfekt luftdicht
verstaut es riecht do nicht in den
Schränken und ihr habt eben alles
griffbereit hier habe ich nicht alles
voll gemacht denn wichtig ist auch immer
beim Kücher einräumen dass ihr nicht
alle Schränke sofort voll macht denn es
kommt immer mal was dazu es kommt immer
mal was weg und dann habt ihr eben
trotzdem noch genug Platz ohne dass
alles gleich zu voll ist habe mir
gedacht ich packe i mal
Brotbackmischungen und Backmischungen
mit rein da kannst sie gleich was Backen
eine Schublade mit Kochgeschirr also
kochwerkzeug alles von kochblume das
habe ich jetzt hier oben weil man dann
wenn man an der Küchenplatte steht an
der Kochplatte hier sich einfach das
Geschirr rausnehmen
kann hier unten ist dann sozusagen der
Bereich offene Lebensmittel Teil 2 hier
oben sind ja eher so die offenen
Lebensmittel wie Müsli und backvorräte
und hier sind die kochvorräte das heißt
alles was offen ist an Nudeln Reis
Linsen Hülsenfrüchten befindet sich hier
auf verschiedenen Ebenen dann sind wir
jetzt hier eigentlich schon am letzten
Bereich nämlich beim Kochbereich und
beim Vorbereitungsbereich hier oben im
Eckschrank würde ich euch empfehlen
Dinge zu verstauen die ihr nicht jeden
Tag braucht denn beim Eckschrank ist es
so dass ich zwei Handgriffe brauche um
ihn zu öffnen habe aber da richtig viel
Stauraum drin auch hier ist der Stauraum
noch gar nicht komplett ausgenutzt ich
habe jetzt hier alle großen Schalen rein
die flottelotte die nudelgeräte hier
noch ein paar auflaufforen oder auch
eine Tortenplatte und das kann man dann
wirklich optimal ausnutzen schön
verstauen und vor allem ist alles gut
übersichtlich aber alles was ich so
täglich brauche habe ich entweder hier
oder hier auf ergonomischer Höhe und da
ist immer besser man hat nur einen
Handgriff hier oben die Dunstabzugshaube
und wie gesagt Platz für Wochenplan
Stundenpläne oder eben andere Dinge
finde ich perfekt weil man es hier
einfach wieder individuell beschriften
kann und hier sind wie gesagt die
Küchentücher Küchenrolle und einfach
noch so zwei drei andere
Vorräte und dann habe ich hier den
Kochbereich hier habe ich Gewürze
verräumt schön in kleinen Vorratsdosen
dann natürlich die löffelablage es gibt
übrigens eine neue löffelablage die ich
auch genial finde weil es eine flache
löffelablage ist die man hier hinlegt
und wenn man dann hier kocht und z.B den
Kochlöffel ablegen will hier am Kochen
und die Arbeitsfläche nicht sa nicht
schmutzig machen will legt man einfach
den Kochlöffel hier ab und alles ist
sauber ich liebe meine kochlöffelablage
das habe ich hier genauso wie die
induktionsmatte oder auch die Messer und
eben auch so ein paar
untersätzer so alles wieder schön
verstauen hier ist eine Schublade die
ich einfach leer gelassen habe damit
annarie und Thomas auch noch selbst
alles Reinräumen können was Sie
vielleicht noch brauchen oder auch
möchten und hier unten dann so ein
bisschen diese vorbereitungssachen sowas
wie Rührschüsseln falzsiebe Messbecher
Trichter und hier außen einfach in dem
Bereich wo ich auch die Küchentücher
habe zum hinhängen finde ich übrigens
perfekt dass man hier nasse Tücher
reinhängen kann denn ich muss sagen ich
hasse es wenn Tücher irgendwo am
Backofen hängen ich häng es dann am
liebsten da rein dann ist es verstaut
sieht ordentlich aus und fertig und
jetzt zeige ich euch einmal noch kurz
die Küchengeräte bei den Küchengeräten
habe ich natürlich auch wieder
Küchengeräte von Bosch ausgesucht die
die beiden wirklich super bedien können
und zwar gibt's einen Backofen in einer
Standardgröße das ist ein Backofen der
wirklich alles kann ein Backofen der
Serie 8 mit ganz normalen Heizarten wie
Ober und Unterhitze mit voreingestellten
Programmen und favoritenfunktionen mit
homeconnect damit auch wirklich alle
Küchengeräte mit dem Handy steuerbar
sind und man z.B die Einstellwerte vom
Handy vom Smartphone aus direkt an den
Ofen senden kann ich habe hier aber auch
noch eine Dampffunktion mit dabei für
voldldampf oder auch verschiedene neue
Funktionen wie airfry z.B WE der Platz
auch hergegeben hat gibt's aber auch
noch einen Kompaktbackofen mit
integrierter Mikrowelle s dass auch
Essensreste wunderbar erwärmt werden
können und die beiden wenn sie vor allem
viel kochen wollen auch zwei Backöfen
gleichzeitig nutzen können man kann
wirklich wunderbar die Kombigeräte
verwenden weil sie einfach viele
Funktionen miteinander verknüpfen und
man so eben viel Platz und Stauraum
sparen kann außerdem gibt's noch das
Induktionskochfeld plus Dunstabzugshaube
und dann fehlen jetzt nur noch einen
voll integrierten Geschirspüler und eine
einbaau gefrier und Kühlkombination mit
Gefrierfach und und jetzt hole ich die
zweimal so ihr zwei dürft gerne kommen
da kommt sie gerannt sie kommt
gerannt hallo herzlich
willkommen in eurer neuen Küche
[Musik]
ja und wie gefällt euch boah ja klasse
Farben oh da freue ich mich aber ganz
besonders
Farben und das ist so lien Öl und das
mit dem Tee das ist ja perfekt wenn ihr
wollt zeige ich euch ein bisschen was ja
ja ja ja ja hab vitrinke oh das pas
schön so warm derchier dass ihr hier
Kaffee trinken könnt und schön eben
alles zubereiten könnt guck mal da eure
Gläser
boah ja
ich hab hier deine backsachen die gerne
ergänzen darfst hier eure Vorräte man
mann
mann K anfangen kochen da hab zwei
Geräte und zwar eine Backofen mit
Dampffunktion da könnt ihr drin dämpfen
dünsten aber auch ganz herkömmliche
Heizarten benutzen oberunterhitze
Heißluft was auch immer für Pizza auch
Pizza mit extra die ganzen Bleche habe
ich hier oben drin und ihr habt noch
ordentlich Platz also die Küche ist noch
ungefähr zu 40 50% leer also ihr könnt
noch so vieles Reinräumen ja weil ihr
richtig viel Stauraum habt das war euch
ja so wichtig falls du mal eine tart
zubereitest habe ich dir tartformen mit
Hebeboden gut die machst du dann da rein
ich hab jetzt nur raus gemacht
das genau D kannst von unten raus und
die Platte passt perfekt von der Größe
her können das da drauf
servieren
so viel
geschm
danke das ist bei B Spülmaschinen so
alles was gefärbt ist ist praktisch zum
verstellen da muss ich e mal Schulung
machen mit den ganzen gerätenes nachdem
was für große oder kleine
teileen
genau viel arbeitche für dich das
woll
[Musik]
hier so ein bisschen Vorräte und
Annemarie weil ich ein bisschen größer
bin als du ja so
kleines ganz
Kleinchen habe ich gedacht kriegst du im
guck und dann kommst du auch bis ganz
nach
oben hast du alles drin oh das ist ja
toll genau gewürzmüllen hier wenn ihr
euch morgens mal Eier machen wollt oder
was anderes drin könnt auch in Ofen
stellen oder auf Grill alles aus i darf
auf Grill und den Ofen und hier Thomas
eher für dich dann auf deiner Höhe auch
noch viel Platz und ich dachte dass ich
dir das hier mit verschlossenen
Behältern mach weil wenn du Gewürze hast
und die mit Tee zusammen verstaust dann
riecht es immer und dann kann man das
schön verau sehr
[Musik]
schön
ja ich habe gedacht hier V hier könnt
euch gerne Wochenpläne machen oder
Einkaufszettel das würde dir gefallen
der will immer so ein Plan und ich bin
einfach
jemand eigentlich
ichum weil ich immer den eigentlich habe
ich da jetzt keine
also das ist so schwer für denas aber ja
Liebesbotschaften reinchreiben also da
bin ich ja vielleicht
[Musik]
für hier noch mal Vorratsbehälter für
angefangenes essen
Lebensmittelvorräte das ist aber echt
tolle Idee aber du bist Profi
weil auf die K wir Ken schon so viel
Jahre und auf die IDE irgendwie so wie
man oder
so aber das ist echt super aber es ist
immer aus der Blick von außen weil in
seiner eigenen Küche man sieht
irgendwann nicht mehr wenn jemand von
außen kommt und dann habe ich da ein
anderen Blick und denke mir vielleicht
kN man das hier oder da logischer
einräumen ja ja aber das
ist was ist so euer Highlight also mein
Highlight darf so erstmal dass du da
bist und das alles für uns gemacht hast
das finde ich richtig super und
überhaupt vom Gerät angefangen bis auf
Deine speziellen Sachen ktopf und so und
dieses schöne Vitrine mit dem Licht ich
mag es lichtvoll also insofern wirklich
das würde ich sagen
und wunderschöne
Arbeitsplatte das freut mich also und
die Farben ja also genial geniale
Zusammensetzung dein Geschmack da drin
einfach wirklich das ist richtig schön
das freut mich richtig war nlich super
aufgeregt so gespannt auch letztenendes
und also das ist wunderschön wunderschön
vielen vielen Dank ja ich danke euch
auch fürs Vertrauen und natürlich auch
richtig toll dass der Freddy die Küche
nicht für sich sondern einfach für euch
als Eltern ausges hat das F ich so
berührend und fand ich so schön weil es
so seine Dankbarkeit euch
geg Famil ich h auch gleich dazu ich
würde mal sagen ich gebe euch einfach
schon mal zwei Gläser gleich drauf
anstoßen und ich bedanke mich ganz ganz
herzlich bei euch fürs Einschalten es
war für mich wieder eine Ehre eine neue
pimp my kitchen Folge zu machen vor
allem jetzt hier für die Community ich
bedanke mich bei allen Partnern die das
möglich gemacht haben und falls ihr noch
mehr Küchen sehen wollt dann schaut
einfach auf pimpmkitchen.de vorbei da
seht ihr alle vergangenen Küchen aber es
kommen natürlich auch einige Küchen noch
mit dazu das heißt wenn ihr noch mehr
Küchen sehen wollt gerne diesen Kanal
abonnieren hier gibt's auch weiterhin
tolle rezeptvideos organisationsvideos
zubereitungsvideos viele viele DIYs und
ich hoffe euch gefällt das Format wenn
ja dann schreibt gerne in die Kommentare
mein Team und ich freuen uns sehr denn
gerade pimp my kitchen ist ein sehr
aufwendiges Format und wir brauchen da
sehr sehr viel Zeit dafür deswegen
freuen wir uns umso mehr über euer
Feedback also macht's gut bis zum
nächsten Mal und
[Musik]
tschüss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
เ เ
เ